spider-man is swinging back into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and it's all
because of you
Disney Co chairman alan horne and Sony
Pictures Chairman Tom Rothman recently
took part in a roundtable discussion in
which they agreed that if not for
pushback from fans this summer splits
which temporarily saw the wall-crawler
Elstad from the MCU might have remained
permanent if your recall horn and
Walkman managed to hammer out the finer
points of a deal which will allow Tom
Hollands pizza pockets were appearing at
least one more solo film set in the MCU
as well as one additional as-yet-unnamed
Marvel Studios picture when it was
reported in August at Sony and Disney
Marvel's parent company had failed to
reach an agreement to extend their
shared custody arrangements of old
webhead fan backlash was instant and
furious and this said horn was
ultimately what convinced the involved
parties to get the deal done Horne
explained the fan base which is
important to all of us seem to Revis
pond to what Tom and his folks have done
before with our people they like the
fact that the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and Marvel Studios had honcho Kevin
Feige were involved in spider-man
homecoming and spider-man far from home
we heard feedback out there that
suggested that joining forces once again
was probably really a good idea might
you try that on and I'll introduce the
world
the newest official member of the
Avengers spider-man Owen apparently is a
master of understatement Twitter
absolutely exploded in the wake of the
news that Sonia Marvel were divorcing
with a large chunk of fans simply beside
themselves with shock and grief Holland
himself did his best to console them
during an appearance at Disney's d23
Expo the following weekend and it may
have been during that event that the
young star upon seeing just how much his
version of the character meant to
Marvel's fans decided upon a course of
action that few in his position would be
gutsy enough to take he reportedly got
in touch with Disney CEO Bob Iger one of
the most powerful people in the world of
entertainment and told him in no
uncertain terms that he needed to get
Sony back to the table then he allegedly
put in a call to Rothman to tell him the
same thing in probably the ploy didn't
backfire ridiculously Holland's kept his
job the two sides got back together a
deal was struck and the fans rejoiced
spider-man is back in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but now fans have
another question for how long a Spidey's
days really numbered
you are a criminal a menace and the good
people of this nation will squash you
like the bug you are whether the deal
will continue after Spidey completes his
MTU solo film and team-up appearance is
a giant question mark but given the fact
that there are tons and tons of box
office bugs to be made by keeping fans
happy we tend to think that it's more
likely than not
of course the question was put to
ruffman joint ehrs roundtable and while
he didn't enthusiastically answer in the
affirmative he also didn't say no and
it's pretty obvious that he recognizes
the value of the partnership the query
was framed in an odd way with the
interviewer mentioning that Sony has
quote shown it can do spider-man without
Marvel by way of the oscar-winning
animated film spider-man into the spider
verse Rothman responded yes we have but
I agree with Horne this was a classic
win win win a win for Sony a win for
Disney a win for the fans the only thing
I would say is that news cycles and the
rhythm of negotiations do not
necessarily overlap and this is in the
words of Shakespeare a consummation
devoutly to be wish'd we would have
gotten there and the news got ahead of
some things there's actually quite a bit
to unpack in their statements not the
least of which has worth Monza parent
Shakespeare fandom and the seemingly
disingenuous suggestion that the media
got ahead of the negotiations as most
details that was being reported was
coming directly out of the mouths of the
involved parties in September
Sony CEO Tony Vince Akira went so far as
to say the quote door was closed on
Spidey to return to the MCU
he said at the time spider-man was fine
before the event movies did better with
the event movies and now that we have
our own universe he will play off the
other characters as well I think we're
pretty capable of doing what we have to
do here thankfully the fan backlash and
Holland's timely intervention pushed the
studio's back together and now that
they're back in business it seems
unlikely that anyone involved will be
keen to go through such a trying public
ordeal again
Feige has in the past teased his
willingness to consider crossing over or
even merging Sony's budding Cinematic
Universe with the MCU
because even before the whole kerfuffle
he knew that I ger Horne and Rothman had
to learn the hard way Spyder fans like
their webslinger
right where he is what are you doing
oh this is nice Spidey's ass yet
untitled third MTU solo Alton hits a big
screen on July 16th 2021 fingers crossed
that it delivers on that far from home
cliff hunger check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bowel so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]